tout le monde connaît pascal sottens
mais parfois davantage pour son prénom
que pour son nom lacarne ans de pascal
le grand frère en quelques années marqué
l'univers de la télévision avec son ton
unique et ses pratiques bien à lui
je vous en comptant sur tf1 de 2006 à
2013 cet animateur pas comme les autres
est à l'origine de quelques unes des
séquences les plus cultes de la télé des
séquences qui aujourd'hui encore sur
internet sont devenus des mêmes en 2010
est il de retour sur ces huit toujours
dans son rôle de coach de vie pas comme
les autres je m'appelle pascal je suis
éducateur après devenu une star de la
télé il fera même un passage par la
fiction dans les mystères de l'amour aux
messieurs voix mais plus récemment
pascal stenz a connu des moments
difficiles sur lesquels il s'est confié
jordan de luxe aujourd'hui soit 441
euros je crois que jean luc tu gagnes
400 euros par mois
notre grand frère à tous pascal fontaine
est avec nous ce soir et il va nous dire
ce que sont devenus les adolescents dont
il s'est occupé d'autres voies
wii et wii sont devenus quoi les
adolescents dont s'occupait pascal le
grand frère pascal sautès merci mon
pascal d'être là merci merci michael
jansen suis très content de te voir vos
pascal que j'aime beaucoup et maeva
alors on y va on va savoir ce qu'elle
est venue parce que my back et les
extrêmes ayvaz je peux vous dire ça
rigolait pas oui c'est bon d'être là oui
alors on pascal des chats qui alors ta
chaîne youtube elle cartonne ouija 160
mille abonnés c'est sa baisse en trois
mois avec un mec qui aime d'ailleurs qui
bossait sur l'émission auparavant avec
volaille marine vous connaissez bien
j'aime ce club et ses poulains de 3 ans
sur les bien sûr on y enseigne c'est ça
on adore
jean marc et jean marc jean marc miche
auriez très bon jean marc et je veux un
bisou mon chéri on va revenir sur des
séquences est donc aujourd'hui tu as
créé la chaîne youtube et on aimerait
savoir ce que sont devenus tous ses
environs et tous et adopter des moyens
une séquence de sos ma famille a besoin
d' aide qui avait beaucoup marqué à
l'époque c'est celle où tu viens on aide
un jeune qui s'appelle armand mais ça
avait plutôt mal démarré parce qu'il a
failli utilisé un marteau contre toi
regardez jetés dans les plus importants
submergé par la colère armand se jette
sur son marteau je te fais moi tu veux
dire et moi c'est des séquences à quoi
pascal que tu as tes nouvelles d'armand
ou pas alors aujourd'hui j'ai plus
nouvelle donc je sais que ça va ça va
mieux que sa maman je crois qu'ils se
brosse les dents maintenant pour pour le
côté un peu comique parce que c'est
quelqu'un qui avait un problème
d'hygiène
ouais aujourd'hui ça va mieux donc il
prend soin de lui ça y est enfin ça y
est c'est la confiance et c'est parti
pour le marteau vraiment aimé ça c'est
vrai que tu as tu t'es dit faut que ça
intervienne vite ouais mais c'est le
coup du marteau je n'ai pas vu venir
ouais ça c'est vraiment du la mito
jamais faut dire aujourd'hui at-elle
chine qui est choqué ouais je suis je
suis bouche bée
j'ai une question quel émotionnellement
cantonnés sur un tournage comme ça quand
on rentre le soir et qu'on a eu des
insultes des trucs des rixes comme ça
comment est-ce qu'on sent le soir très
dur très dur
moi j'ai discuté beaucoup au club si ce
qu'est une psychologue qui nous suivent
sur l'émission chaque soir j'allais déjà
les débriefer avec elle parce que je
gardais trop trop de choses en commun
arriva que j'évacue voit effectivement
elle me dit attention parce qu'à c'est
un travail je mettais trop d'empathie et
puis m'ont témoigné parfois je craque
elle conte mais j'ai pas franchement
pascal massicot short démission et moi
j'ai un petit d'ailleurs qui en régie
voilà qui me sauve après l'émission
ils me disent ils mais il m'a dit aussi
moi aussi il faut que j'évacue je veux
dire de quoi il faut évacuer quoi faut
il pas qu on va voir un autre extrait
c'est quand à moi je me rappelle de
celui-là métier que je suis fan absolu
moi je remercie allah je regardais mais
c'est à dire que mais je n'en manquait
pas
lorsque tu essaies de me relancer
l'émission a baissé je suis fou de cette
émission c'est vrai que cette émission
pascal c'est incroyable voilà je refais
mon jeu l'adorent et quand essayé de
bouger un peu le jeune mounir préfère
rester dans son lit
on y est
alors allez
klaus taussac
je ne joue pas
quant au cobaye qu'est ce que c'est dans
ce qui s'est dit
de quoi tu te lèves tu accomplis ou pas
parce que tu veux pas crever cosumaf the
path relevé gentiment non c'est
maintenant se réveille c'est fini je
suis sérieux je termine mon salon
n'diaye bah alors mooneea moignard très
compliqué ce que j'ai revu un an après
cette émission dans une émission qui
s'appelait à l'époque à un boulot pour
mon ado et ça s'est mal fini d'ailleurs
avec lui et aujourd'hui je sais pas du
tout ce qui ne peut pas être honnête je
dirais je parce que il a quitté il a
quitté l aventure dont qu'il était avant
la fin de tournage donc c'était très
compliqué avec très très connu pour les
faits légers pour la prod c'était dur
fait des bisous est-ce qu'à des moments
où c'est vraiment allé trop loin avec du
moment où vous avez coupé au montage
gullit a pu montrer away we go away
renée des bastons janvier non non c'est
pas lui c'est la première fois que je le
dis donc là c'est une exclu un temps
pour que vous l'avez pas toi tu as
vraiment genre et ça c'est à pékin
ouais je dis que c'est de la violence
gratuite à partir en nous il ya des
insultes
moi quand on insulte à mon et voilà ça
déborde et quand ça déborde
c'était trop fort pour moi je me suis
défendu à quelqu'un qui vous
[Rires]
c'est beaucoup ont poussé la scène
annexe pour dire ce que ça dure
longtemps
ouais bah si c'est avec mounir en plus
un donc moi je moi je les aime mes yeux
ronds jamais diffusés avec vraiment ça
dure une minute vingt ans fait vraiment
de cartes à une minute vingt deux
bagarres
moi je suis déjà castagnet castaldi ça
dure dix ou madame mais oui je le laisse
croire qu'ils font c'est quand même mon
patron c'est pas faux mais ce serait
quand même dommage que plus que serré
stones voilà au fond là ça va ça va
lacoste majorettes j'aime bien une autre
voie tu n'y est pas allé de main morte
ainsi avec un jeune qui s'appelle boris
ont extrait qu'on vas voir tu n'hésites
pas lui mettre une balayette voisin
ainsi chabal est pédagogique ah bah
écoute voilà ce que je faisais c'était
john oui oui encore et encore
jeudi encore encore éclaté salage koné
s'est étonné dans le truc que tu t'es
laissé aller à l'embrasser et lui ça va
et ça c'est bon ils sont motos sont en
couple un tous quasiment donc encore ils
sont quasiment tous des enfants donc
minime demande de ce que tu peux leur
gamin maintenant je vois tous ces
enfants comme toutes les femmes de
benjamin alors et moi c'est un extrait
vraiment incroyable c'est celui avec
jean-marc un joli mais bien utilisé le
mot amour ça point c'est un des plus
grands extraits de pascal legros frais à
regarder c'est pas moi je sais pas ce
que moi je te découvrir son jeu c'est
même lui qui a gelé un féru ce que ça
veut dire moi j'ai déjà mon âge ça veut
dire bonjour tu mets un quartier toits
donc ouais ça veut dire quoi vous utile
cette réserve bon jour
cette fois je vais arrêter de répéter
des mots sans savoir la signification
mais bonjour c'est salam aleikoum si tu
prends la langue alors le parler tétouan
écoute on va apprendre à l'école
toi aussi tu dis ouais c'est incroyable
et il ya dans notre édition tu as
découvert david aussi un adolescent qui
visiblement avaient du mal à faire des
phrases comme celui-là aussi était
présent mais en plus en plus d'agir si
vous avez repris ouais c'est moi
derrière je fais aussi également une
feuille cours des divers sujets
complément c'est une phrase sévère
sujets comme les autres
il ya un problème à parler c'est le
pauvre garçon j'approuve a déjà prouvé
tes preuves certaines personnes
ce à dire que tes preuves en apprend à
t'exprimer correctement déjà jusque là
voilà voilà quoi c'est à dire ça
débouchait des travers de sujets
concrets mon activité chez apprend
vraiment raté par trop quoi d'un mois
une réponse apprend quoi ballet des jeux
s'est pas démentie qu'est-ce qui doit sa
note qu'est-ce que je bosse à la caisse
c'est pas français ça et alors c'est une
erreur de français non s'exhale rare
c'est que rien mais je tiens pour elle
c'est tout c'est quoi
qu'est ce que j'aimerais si les anges
après ce n'est pas vrai jus rien j'en ai
vraiment au 6/9 erreur de fond c'était
rigolo quand je me tiendrai cas ce que
la bct gentiment vers doha avant que ces
adorables vraiment un petit jeune aura
bien moi j'aimais bien j'ai mes loisirs
sont aussi j'avais je vois jamais bien
accroché cuit david site à alamo et
j'aurais courrier dotc tu te rappelles
de quentin oui oui oui il me reçoit bien
d'ailleurs il m'insulte arrive
d'hectares l on voit qu'il est content
tu ne comprends pas que pascal vient
d'entrer dans la maison
oh
ah ouais
non jamais dit ça j'ai entendu je crois
non non je vois tu m'insultes quel soin
de toi oui non c'est pas si loin que ça
dit quoi à wade sait qui tu et à toi je
te vois tu me vois arriver tu me vois là
j'entends une insulte que ces sociétés
exploitent et pardon c'est pour dire que
jabron jours déjà chaud bonjour qui
contient ou bonjour qui bonjour tu fait
de ton malin non et puis il était gentil
aussi bas c'est un garçon gentil un peu
perdu mais voilà en fait j'ai joué
l'homme de la maison puisque leur ait
pas été plus là il était alors ils sont
tous touchants il va aller avec nous
merci pascal de nous avoir amené my
valenciennes du programme aussi parce
qu'elle était venue à tout ce qu il faut
dire que tu étais une jeune à souligner
d'adolescents tracé colérique la chaude
voix toute calme avec ta mère et ton
beau père s'est il une autre limonade
comment buzz pardon dégage voilà suis
planté là
[Musique]
ça fait quoi
ok tu touches patois
quand on voit ces images c'est quelque
chose ouais vraiment quoi ça nous fait
de la peine quand ça me fait toujours
c'était comme un temps 5 au bout non
j'ai toujours aucun cas normal parce que
même nous on n en voit ça parce que
c'est vrai que la ccc view voilà mais
comment ça se passe aujourd'hui ça va
très bien je parle encore à ma mère
ouais elle a changé de copains du coup
d'accord moi je dis vive et sont
maintenant que le corps est là je parle
très très bien ma mère tous les jours a
relaté nouvelle
cette voie là demain soeur c'est pareil
mon frère on a tous temps des nouvelles
d'eux et essai c'est grâce à pascal
aussi tu t'es senti mieux dans la
famille oui vraiment il ya eu un avant
et un après ouais bah maintenant les
mamans pas changé je suis maman d'une
petite fille maintenant un signe
formidable ça va faire trois ans que
j'ai avec mon copain et tout ça se passe
très bien ça va très très très bien et
donc avec ta petite fille tu essaies de
répondre aux soins font pas ce que j'ai
dit je n'ai pas envie que dwayne j'ai
vraiment pas envie qu'elle fasse comme
moi voilà c'est ça ouais vraiment donc
tu sais vraiment attention à tout ce
qu'elle fait parce que sinon celle fait
comme moi après j'appelle pascal je
regrette ce jour de ce genre de moments
ouais bah il m'a énormément fin il m'a
énormément aidé et il m'a énormément
manqué au bout de cinq ans et enfin
c'est grâce à lui tout ça quoi bah c'est
bon parce qu'elle compte en temps ça
ouais c'est vraiment ce que ça m'émeut
quoi donc la lamal est prêt je sais
quand je vois ça effectivement je me dis
que ce métier il était juste formidable
et de le faire à travers la télévision
et se retourna après cinq ans quand je
vois ce qu'elle est devenue pour la
plupart ça me touche quoi donc voilà
donc merci merci à toi d'avoir d'avoir
fait ce qu'il fallait pour changer c'est
bien bravo
oui nicolas rivenq pardon si la nuit
c'est dur à regarder du ccg désolé parce
que l'image c'est un peu dur à regarder
qu'est ce qui s'est passé à ce qu'est ce
qui a fait que vous êtes sortis de cette
violence
vous l'avez compris parce qu'il ya cette
émission qui est extraordinaire moi je
pense que c'est une émission d utilité
publique qui avait vraiment sa place les
flammes sur le service public à l'époque
alors parce que ma peine est proposé
mais je l'aurais pris je vous lirai
suffisamment respectés les auditions
attendait propose est émission à le
faire elle sert aux pats ont perdu parce
que ces violences
je suis en plus qui est effroyable elle
sert c'est une émission utilité publique
qui manquent cruellement et télévision
mais comment vous êtes sorti de ça parce
que effectivement parce qu'elle a fait
son job mais vous étiez dans une colère
dans une violence qui est ce qu était le
le déclencheur pour sortir de ça je sais
que c'est dur où on en parlait en fait
si je suis devenu comme ça c'est en
partie par rapport au décès de mon
grand-père est à 8 ans encore à l'heure
actuelle et pascal m'a parlé hors caméra
du coût de son papa et ça m'a énormément
touché de me dire qu'il n'ya pas que moi
en fait je souffre de quelque chose et
du coup franchement ça m'a vraiment ça
m'a vraiment senti mieux de savoir que
quelqu'un d'autre pouvait ressentir ce
que moi je refais un l'heure actuelle il
m'a énormément aidé énormément touché
sur ce qui me disait c'est un tout maeva
en tout cas je te souhaite beaucoup de
bonheur mais vraiment il à ce que sont
heureuses de sang et emmanuel merci
maeva pascal que ses comptes m non si je
vous aime
j'espère quand tu sais quoi il faudrait
peut-être même faire une séquence un
jour des pmp tu vois peut-être déjà on a
resserré de revenus que sont ils devenus
à exactes sont ils devenus pour qu'ils
puissent expliquer le chemin qu'ils ont
parcouru la presse est émis un certain
ne veut plus veut plus passer à la
saison girondine mais j'en ai pas les
idées de nouveaux jeunes aussi
il ya encore beaucoup de demandes de pas
mal de jeunes ont besoin d'être aidés
quoi merci mon pascal merci à vous merci
cartonne et tu le mérites
et j'espère qu'on va trouver abonnez
vous avec ou sans soixante mille abonnés
sur la chaîne youtube place de pascal
cuttat merci merci madame